coronavirus is the hot topic these days
yet there is something nobody has talked
about how does the Chinese health care
system work here on visual politic we've
talked about how China reacted to the
pandemic but now we want to focus on how
their health care system may or may not
play a role in this after watching this
video you will understand a fundamental
piece in this whole puzzle so let's get
started
[Applause]
[Music]
here is the question we will all be
asking in 30 years where were you during
the you coronavirus crisis and I'm sure
we will all remember pictures like this
yes we've all seen those news stories
about China sending aid European
countries some media outlets or even
praising China for how they did what was
needed in order to contain the
infections nevertheless there is
something we still need to know how does
China's health care system work could
the corona virus become the Chinese
shinobi
[Music]
China has been characterized by very low
level lift non-existent health
regulations if you travel to China you
might have seen the wet markets where
food is handled without gloves and there
are hardly any hygiene controls this is
why we started researching more about
their hospitals and their health care is
it private is it state-sponsored how
does it work and well this video is
probably going to blow your mind
[Music]
so now the question is does China
deserve such a bad reputation for the
health care system why is it that so
many Chinese people don't want to visit
the doctor and the most important
question of all does the Chinese
Communist Party have some responsibility
for the spread of this disease and yes
we're going to answer all of those
questions but before we do it's time to
talk about health so we're going to be
joined by dr. Amiya Duan here as a
wonderful channel about health in
Spanish called globular Azul and by the
way if you sprechen sie Deutsch we've
now got visual politic in German so I'm
gonna link to that below do go check it
out if you speak German arm and leg in
1949 Mao Zedong rose to power in China
he found a vast country that seemed
frozen in time in most of the Chinese
villages talking about modern medicine
was like talking about the internet
having no budget to train the required
doctors he came up with a creative
solution the so-called barefoot doctors
[Music]
the success of method doctors was its
expansiveness the program reached 90% of
China the medical knowledge was not
profound but it provided three basic
services attending childbirth which
reduced infant mortality carrying out
wide scale vaccinations which was vital
for preventing infectious diseases and
improving information on the basic
hygiene habits of the population which
went a long way in preventing potential
epidemics and yes I know you're probably
dying to know Simon did they really not
wear any shoes well no they totally did
have shoes but they were in the
countryside so if they wanted to attend
to someone in the rice paddies well
they'd have to take their shoes off if
they wanted them to last until the next
five-year plan
but during 1980s and 90s these barefoot
doctors became outdated the country was
growing fast and the people prospered
everything was good except two things
environments and healthcare China health
care costs for some patients into
crippling debt fortune think about it
the modern market friendly China wanted
modern hospitals those beffort doctors
sounded like a thing of the past and the
quickest way to get those modern
hospitals was through a private system
the existing health system was
eventually privatized China's new
economic policy required that Chinese
people make money lots of money enough
to pay their medical bills in other
words they wanted to move from a system
of equally Porter hey wouldn't it be
better to all be rich China's economic
growth in these decades is evidence the
problem is the usual one inequality by
2000 only 30 percent of China's
population at health insurance their
status show up with money in hand
a medical consultation was roughly
equivalent to a month's salary what's
more in rural areas medical attention
left a lot to be desired
so therefore the Chinese prefer to go to
hospitals in the city the average
week-long stay in a hospital could set
you back the equivalent of three months
salary in addition China is the only
country in East Asia that charges for
childhood vaccines faced with the
scenario diseases that China once said
under control have returned this is the
case with tuberculosis measles and snail
fever the worst thing for the Chinese is
that health care costs them an arm and a
leg and on top of that I have to tip the
doctor if they want to be treated well
Chinese doctor took more than 18 million
dollars worth of bribes says report the
Guardian however things have changed in
the past ten years how let's take a look
[Music]
milene viagra when the SARS crisis
occurred in 2003 the government decreed
that those affected would receive free
treatments but this Creators a quandary
for the population how many Chinese
people didn't go to the doctor for fear
that theirs was the normal flu and then
they'd get an unwelcome bill if your
population is afraid to go to the doctor
this is a problem for any country
reforms of the health system that began
in China in 2009 have gradually brought
about changes the main one is now that
95 percent of the population has health
insurance but hold on a moment because
this hasn't solved the problems either
insurance only covers between 50 and 75
percent of the cost so when the disease
is severe and treatment is expensive the
Chinese have to dig deep and not
everyone can do that
[Music]
in fact China's health system combines
the worst of both worlds the worst from
a fully private system and the worst
from a universal care one on the one
hands the government wants to help
citizens cover the cost of health care
but on the other hand they need to
control public spending so what do they
do well there are limits to the amount
of subsidized treatments that hospitals
can claim from the government
approximately one thousand seven hundred
dollars per patients in the best
hospitals considerably less in rural
areas as a result very few patients will
spend more than two weeks in hospital
regardless of whether or not they're
healthy
[Applause]
so it seems whichever way you look at us
the system is inefficient on the one
hand hospitals are being encouraged to
treat their mildly all patients to
collect the maximum subsidies from the
states but on the other hands there is
little interest in caring that seriously
ill patients with this or means to pay
the difference
[Music]
and on top of that the cost of
healthcare is multiplied for the state
to what extent fell by about three
hundred billion dollars a year to put
that in perspective that amount is the
same as Chile's total GDP or the
equivalents to the entire Mexican annual
budget as you can imagine this is a huge
mess it's bad health care combined with
huge government spending so the
Communist Party officials met one day
and they came up with something
different and what do you think this
great solution was
get ready for this traditional Chinese
medicine and now this isn't just
something for tourists many Chinese
continue to believe in the ancient
traditions that have been passed down
from generation to generation most of
the people still rely on herbs
acupuncture and gymnastics in 2016 the
Chinese government regulated the
traditional medicine practice and
because they needed doctors they relaxed
all the requirements to be a doctor you
used to have to get a degree in
conventional medicine and then
specialize in other fields now you've
just needed to know about traditional
medicine and have two colleagues who are
willing to endorse you yep that's right
but hold on for a moment because at the
time of making this video there were
already more than 4,000 traditional
medicine hospitals in China think I'm
exaggerating you think this is a
conspiracy the truth is that as far as
the Chinese officials are concerned this
is far from a secret to be hidden in
fact the traditional Chinese medicine
also referred to as TCM is something to
be proud of just check this out
china now has 4,000 238 traditional
Chinese medicine hospitals with 877
thousand beds the news is not from any
anti China Western imperialist outlets
this is from Xinhua at the official news
from the Chinese Communist Party in
other words they brag about how much
they use their traditional Chinese
medicine and this is especially popular
in rural areas so for example some
treatments include dried geckos
according to some those would cure some
types of tumors if you have erectile
dysfunction you could try the so called
himalayan viagra this is a mushroom that
grows you guessed it in the Himalayan
mountains and the demand for these
mushrooms has increased so much lately
that one kilo of this miraculous natural
medicine can cost more than 110 thousand
dollars and I know what some of you
might say well this currently a debate
even in Western countries about
traditional Chinese medicine but so far
there is no clear evidence that it works
both the British NHS and the American
Secretary of Health do not advise these
treatments
then again the w-h-o is included some of
the traditional practices for diagnostic
purposes only we should also consider
that China is a member of the w-h-o and
they have been lobbying for decades in
order to promote TCM and maybe some of
you are thinking right now well they
might not do anything but I mean the
natural remedies they can't be bad for
you right well you better think again
[Music]
report one-fifth of China's soil
contaminated BBC so to give you an
example in 2013 they discovered that
some rice harvested in China contained
cadmium cadmium is an element that can
cause cancer this is just one of the
many scandals so if there is
contaminated rice there could also be
contaminated herbal treatments think
about it this way when you release a
brand new pole to the market you have to
go through lots of clinical trials
meanwhile all the Malayan viagra comes
straight from the field so it's much
harder to detect dangerous trace
elements so at this point you might be
wondering well what does this have to do
with coronavirus Simon well get ready
[Music]
bats are back in ten I don't want any of
you are thinking what's the problem with
traditional medicine if you don't
believe in it just don't use it
the problem is when someone turns away
from modern medicine and throws
themselves into the arms of a charlatan
then you get things like this Chinese
alternative medicine Empire is under
fire after doctors say it gave jujube
tea to a four-year-old cancer patient
washington post the other danger of
traditional medicine is ecological for
some reason many traditional treatments
require rare and endangered animals
animals of which there are few specimens
left and then suddenly they become
extremely desirable that's the case with
rhinos pangolins
and bats and here is where coronavirus
comes into the picture
rapid classification of beta
coronaviruses and identification of
traditional chinese medicine as
potential origin zoonotic coronaviruses
of course this is just a study with a
theory you see this is not the first
time that there has been a corona virus
epidemic SARS was also another type of
corona virus and the original host that
passed this virus to humans was a bat
the second corona virus outbreak was
MERS one that originated in Saudi Arabia
in 2012 in this case the animals that
transmitted the virus to humans was a
camel but the camel had been infected by
a bat in other words it seems that some
type of bat might be the natural hosts
for some corona viruses and it turns out
that those types of bats used in
traditional Chinese medicine it's not
yet known what caused the current corona
virus crisis some theories pointed to
bats others pointed at Pangolin
obviously we're visual politic don't
have the answer what we do know is there
is someone influential who encourages
the Chinese people to eat weird things
thinking they will cure all ailments and
he's this guy
see urges enhance efforts to promote
traditional Chinese medicine china daily
so why the big push from the top well it
all comes down to money because
traditional Chinese medicine is cheaper
it is much more popular according to
official Chinese figures traditional
medicine has reduced hospital expenses
by 24% and outpatient costs by 12%
according to Xi Jinping's narrative what
we call science-based medicine is just
Westerners
[Music]
traditional medicine is just another
type it's just as good and as bad a
science maybe it really is better at the
end of the day it's Chinese and it is
4,000 years old after all this must be
the proof that socialism with Chinese
characters is better than Western
democracy right all of this explains
China's efforts of promoting TCM all
over the place at the w8 show and also
in legacy media and do you think I'm
talking about fake news of course not
I'm talking about media outlets like
this one
coronavirus and traditional Chinese
medicine help fight the disease that
headline is from Deutsche Welle which is
the German equivalent of the BBC I mean
we're talking about an authoritative
source with an undisputed reputation and
of course Chinese official media will go
even further
traditional Chinese medicine treatment
effective against novel coronavirus says
official china daily so the question is
are bad based treatments the origin for
coronavirus well we definitely don't
know the answer to that one maybe we
never will there is only one thing we
can tell you if that were true China
would hardly admit it why do we know
that they would act that way or here's a
clue
Chinese doctor silence after warning of
outbreak dies from coronavirus new york
times once again it's up to you to form
your own opinion but it's hard to
imagine china being transparent about
this in fact they have every incentive
to cover this whole crisis up with a
huge dose of propaganda think about it
this way these last two years have been
a nightmare for the regime first the
Hong Kong protests then the trade wars
and now coronavirus this pandemic could
easily become the Chinese Chernobyl just
like Chernobyl this is not a conspiracy
nobody wanted the plant to explode it
was the lack of security measures and
the lack of transparency that led to the
reactor blowing up something similar
could happen here there's no conspiracy
there's no master plan now can we really
say that China has acted responsibly in
this matter do you think the Chinese
health care system did play a role here
and will this coronavirus have a
political impact in China please leave
your answers in the comment section
below before we finish I would like to
thank a Meowth from global resolve for
helping us on this video if you want to
learn more about health in yeah but to
speak Spanish please do check out his
channel and please do visit our friends
and reconsider media the podcast that
provided the vocals in this episode but
well not mine and thank you for watching
if you want to learn more about politics
and world affairs and here's some more
of my lovely voice come check out the
reconsidered podcast where we don't do
the thinking for you find reconsider at
WWE consider mediacom or on Apple or
Google Play or your favorite podcast
[Music]